foreign
[Music]
on September 17 2001 six days after the
9 11 Jihad attacks U.S President George
W bush made one of the biggest mistakes
any president has ever made
Bush appeared at the Islamic Center of
Washington DC in the company of several
prominent Muslim leaders and said
these acts
and violence against innocence violate
the fundamental tenets of the Islamic
faith
and it's important for my fellow
Americans to understand that
the English translation is not as
eloquent as the original Arabic but let
me quote from the Quran itself
in the long run
evil in the extreme
will be the end of those who do evil
for that they rejected the signs of
Allah
and held them up to ridicule
the face of Terror is not the true faith
of Islam
that's not what Islam is all about
Islam is peace
these terrorists
don't represent peace
they represent evil and War
when we think of Islam we think of a
faith that brings Comfort to a billion
people around the world
billions of people
find comfort and solace
and peace
and that's made brothers and sisters out
of every race out of every race
and As Americans still searched the
smoking ruins of the World Trade Center
for the remains of their loved ones
President Bush cautioned Americans
against thinking ill of Muslims as if
the 9 11 attacks had been perpetrated by
Americans targeting Muslims
America counts millions of Muslims
amongst our citizens
and Muslims make it incredibly
valuable contribution to our country
Muslims are doctors
lawyers
law professors
members of the military
entrepreneurs shopkeepers moms and dads
and they need to be treated with respect
in our anger and emotion
our fellow Americans must treat each
other with respect
women who cover their heads in this
country
must feel comfortable going outside
their homes
moms who wear cover
must not be intimidated in America
that's not the America I know
that's not the America I value
I've been told that
some fear to leave
some don't want to go shopping for their
families some don't want to
go about the ordinary daily routines
because by wearing cover they're afraid
they'll be intimidated as should not and
that will not stand in America
those who feel like they can intimidate
our fellow citizens to take out their
anger they'll represent the best of
America
they represent the worst of humankind
and they should be ashamed of that kind
of behavior now this is a great country
it's a great country because we share
the same values of respect and dignity
and human worth
and it is my honor to be meeting with
leaders who feel just the same way I do
they're outraged they're sad
they love America just as much as I do
now Muslims were not at that time being
subjected to wholesale vigilante attacks
in the United States not at that time or
at any point subsequently this speech
was an exercise in vassalage that should
have made him ashamed yet Bush was by no
means alone political leaders all over
the West echoed his words about Islams
being a religion of Peace having nothing
to do with terrorism after September
11th this became a common place of the
western political discourse rejected
only by a small minority who were
quickly stigmatized as bigots and cranks
all these years later it's clear Bush's
speech set the pattern after every Jihad
attack non-muslim leaders have followed
his example making it their highest
priority to affirm that Islam is peace
and the Muslims are victims Bush
deformed the West's response to the
resurgent Jihad and poisoned the public
discourse so that attempts to discuss
this problem honestly are consigned to
the Realms of islamophobia and condemned
by all right things people
as I show in my new book the history of
jihad from Muhammad to Isis Bush's
speech came after 14 centuries of jihad
against non-muslims Bush's willful
ignorance came after so much Jihad
Warfare with so many ruined lives and so
much Bloodshed that its ignorance was
astonishing
but Bush's speech won the day and so the
West's entire approach to the global
Jihad threat since 9 11 has been
astonishingly wrong-headed and is
leading us to political cultural and
societal disaster that so many people
don't know what is happening now is
Bush's most enduring and damaging Legacy
I'm Robert Spencer a showman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy